Is George Monbiot. He's a guardian journalist and author.
His best-selling books include captive state, the corporate takeover of Britain,
the age of consent and manifesto for a new world order.
And most recently out of the wreckage, a new politics for an age of crisis,
George, over to you.
Thanks very much wrestler.
Now I realize that in calling for you to vote for this
motion,
I'm making quite a tough care to call for the end of capitalism
in the 21st century is like saying, God is dead in the 19th.
And perhaps it's a particularly tough ask for people who have paid 30 quid to
get in,
but I know you're a broad minded and intellectually curious bunch,
otherwise you wouldn't be here. So I'm going to ask you hard.
As I know it is to the greatest extent possible to put aside all prior
beliefs and judge the arguments to see evening on their merits,
which of course will inevitably mean that for a hundred, I win this vote.
Um, so what is capitalism?
It might be quite a useful starting point to agree on our terms. Well,
it's an economic system,
which is whose means where the means of production are privately owned
for the purpose of generating profits and accumulating wealth.
It can be distinguished from other forms of profit seeking by the general
commodification of land, labor,
and money as such its origins date back to about the mid 16th century
in England. And as a mature system, it's about 200 years old.
I hope we can all agree broadly on that. As a definition,
I hope we can also all agree on what climate collapses climate collapses,
what happened somewhere North of 1.5 degrees of global
heating above pre-industrial levels.
This is why the Paris agreement calls on the governments,
which have signed it including our own to keep temperature levels
well below two degrees and to seek,
to keep them at 1.5 degrees at two degrees,
we see the loss of almost all the world's coral reefs.
We see ice-free sea at the Arctic becoming a regular event with
devastating consequences as runaway feedbacks,
kick in the dark water, absorbing more heat.
The permafrost releasing its carbon.
We've seen recent papers suggesting what they call multiple
breadbasket failures.
The world's crucial food production regions being taken out at the
same time by simile tenuous heat waves.
We see major cities threatened by inundation. I hope too. We can all agree.
That is climate collapse.
Now I ain't going to argue that capitalism has three essential and intrinsic
features without which it would not be capitalism that drive us
inexorably towards climate collapse.
And the first of these is growth growth.
Essential to capitalism without growth.
Capitalism is deemed to fail.
The rising growth in consumption is the aggregate
impact of profit seeking activities. In other words,
it's the inevitable result of capitalism successfully
practiced.
And this leads to a slight problem that prepared the actual growth,
which is what capitalism seeks on a finite planet.
It leads inexorably to environmental disaster.
Now, those who seek to justify the system will say, well,
hang on a moment that growth can be decoupled from its environmental
impact. So you can have rising growth and falling environmental impacts.
Now we know that where material resource consumption,
the consumption of stuff is concerned that has never been
demonstrated. However,
it does appear to be the case in some nations where greenhouse gas emissions
are concerned. There's a famous study by the world resources Institute,
which said that across developed nations,
the richest nations in the world, 35 richest nations,
we saw between 2020 14,
a general reduction in greenhouse gas emissions,
even as economic growth Rose in those places.
And for instance, in the UK,
we saw a 24% reduction across that period,
even while there was a 27% increase in consumption in, in,
in economics growth. But it's not quite as it seems,
because what that study was looking at is what's called territorial emissions.
The greenhouse gases you produce within your own nation when
carbon brief reanalyzed the figures,
it looked at consumption emissions, greenhouse gases,
for which you're responsible in the goods that your nation imports embodied
in those goods.
And that reduced the 24% to 9% across the 15 years,
about 0.6% a year reductions in greenhouse gases.
When you then take an account take account of flying and shipping,
which are not included in those figures,
it comes out more or less at zero.
Now a recent study by the UN environment program says that to stand a good
chance of preventing more than 1.5 degrees of global,
we need to cut greenhouse gas emissions by 7.6%
per year for the next 10 years,
not zero or not as it may now be minus two minus
7.6%. Well, hang on a minute.
During this entire period of the study, 2000 to 2014,
the British government and the British people in general were making massive
efforts to cut greenhouse gas emissions.
We are past the climate change act.
The government spent billions on subsidizing renewables.
We'd got out of coal largely and into gas, a really important transition,
boom, you know, not important enough, but it should have made a huge difference.
We insulated our homes. We changed our light bulbs.
So how come we were flat lining? Well,
the answer is that those efforts were counteracted by economic growth
that trying to cut your impacts while your economy is growing.
While resource consumption is growing means running down the rising escalator,
it makes it difficult if not impossible.
And the same applies to the next two intrinsic features of capitalism.
The second one is feature,
which has been there since John Locke's second treaties of government and
absolutely central feature of capitalism,
which is the assumption that the money in your bank account equates to your
right to own natural wealth.
You can own as much land as much gold as much.
You can eat as much meat or fish as you want. You can have,
you can create as much burn as much carbon as you like,
as long as you've got the money for that. And because of that,
capitalism is a really lousy way of solving our problems because it
means that those were the money, take the lion's share depriving other people.
And however hard we pursue growth, we cannot solve them.
So one study, for instance,
shows that to reduce poverty by $1,
you need to generate $111 of economic growth
on the current trajectory to ensure that everybody through growth gets
$5 a day. We would, it would take 200 years.
We would need to raise the size of the global economy 170
times. But even at current levels of economic growth,
we are bursting through environmental limits.
170 times is not the end of poverty.
It's the end of life on earth. And then there's the third feature,
which is a promise central to capitalism that everyone can aspire
to private luxury. We can all become rich. Now,
even if it weren't for that distributional problem, which I mentioned,
there's another issue there there's simply not enough environmental space for
everybody to aspire to private luxury.
The only reason that some people can do it is that other people don't
otherwise we end up just cooking ourselves in very short order.
The richest 1% in the world use 175 times
as much carbon as the poorest 10% is everyone's supposed to use the
same amount. These three features of capitalism,
turn it into a gun pointed at the living world.
We cannot sustain a habitable climate and sustain capitalism.
Instead,
we need a system based on a different principle of private sufficiency and
public luxury. There's enough for everyone.
As long as we share it, there is not enough.
As long as we seek to accumulate it and to keep raising our aggregate
and individual consumption,
you cannot make those changes while still calling it capitalism.
There's an old and vaguely attributed saying,
which is that it's easier to imagine the end of the world than it is to imagine
the end of capitalism, my friends.
I want you to mobilize your imaginations tonight.
The question that faces us is do we stop capitalism
to allow life, to continue or stop life,
to allow capitalism to continue? Thank you.
[Inaudible].